During infection by HIV, three enzymes
play essential roles in the life cycle
of the virus: Reverse Transcriptase,
Integrase, and Protease.
The first enzyme, HIV Reverse Transcriptase
copies the viral RNA genome by combining
individual host nucleotides to build a
complementary DNA strand.
When Reverse Transcriptase finishes this strand,
It will replace the original viral RNA with
another DNA strand forming a DNA double helix.
The second enzyme, HIV Integrase
inserts the viral DNA into the cell's DNA.
The third enzyme, HIV Protease is needed
at the last step of the viral life cycle
to cut the HIV polyprotein into its
individual functional parts.
HIV enzymes are targets for drug therapy.
Two types of drugs block Reverse Transcriptase.
Drugs like AZT mimic the normal building
blocks of DNA, but prematurely terminate
the DNA chain. Drugs like nevirapine
bind on the back side of Reverse Transcriptase,
distorting the enzyme so
that it can no longer perform its
DNA building reaction. Raltegravir binds to
two magnesium ions in Integrase that are
essential for the DNA integration reaction.
Drugs likes the Saquinavir mimic
the proteins cut by HIV protease,
blocking the maturation of the virus.
Drug resistance is a major problem for HIV
drug therapy.  For instance, when patients
are treated with drugs that block HIV
Protease, most of the viruses are
destroyed but rare mutant forms of the
virus survive.
These mutant viruses make a mutated form of the Protease.
This Protease resists
the binding of drugs, but can still cut
the viral polyprotein.
Over many generations the population of viruses
builds up additional mutations that
further resist the drug.
The most effective current treatment
method uses a combination of drugs that
attack the different enzymes, so that
some of the drugs will still be active
even if one of the enzymes
becomes resistant.